let me talk briefly about Utah what's
happening in Utah is absolutely
fascinating the background is that
there's this independent Mormon
candidate Evan McMullen and I've told
you that Mormons are really voting their
conscience in a logical way evangelical
Christians they seem to have thrown
morals ethics and their conscience
completely out the window and into the
trash I would argue Donald Trump the
overwhelming support of evangelicals he
had nearly eighty percent support from
evangelical Christians at one point
that's that's dropped to about
two-thirds support but it still makes no
sense from the the the group of voters
that claims to be the moral ethical
majority voting for the guy with the
multiple wives and the wife who has been
in I mean I hesitate to call it
pornography but certainly not material
that you would think would be acceptable
to the evangelical Christians the guy
who for his entire life has been pro
choice although I guess now they've been
bamboozled into thinking Trump is is
actually anti-abortion there's no reason
that evangelical Christians should be
voting for Donald Trump but they are
anyway Mormons on the other hand
particularly Mormons in Utah have said
no they've said Donald Trump is not
represent our conscience he does not
represent our morals and values and by
and large in numbers that we have not
seen in Utah for a very long time
Mormons are not overwhelmingly
supporting Donald Trump and if you look
at early voting in Utah first of all if
you look at polling in Utah it's not a
gimme for Trump this independent Mormon
candidate Evan McMullen is very close to
within the margin of error of leading
the state of Utah that is fascinating in
and of itself but also in early voting
in Utah a third more Utah Democrats have
voted so far then what would normally be
expected in early turnout for by mail
voting and fewer than predicted
Republicans have been casting ballots in
Utah now Pat we don't know how someone
votes but if we know that more Democrats
than expected and fewer Republicans than
expected have been voting that does tell
us something yeah because Utah has been
a ruby red state for Allah
time and I think that Democrats will see
that the the race is closed in a
four-way race and may be encouraged to
go out and vote I don't know about you
but I'm rooting for Evan McMullen in
this race yeah I mean I'm rooting for
the Republican candidate not winning
that it you know Evan McMullen I saw him
on CNN this morning giving this quite
frankly delusional perspective where if
he can win Utah and one other state and
if the math works out so that he blocks
both candidates from getting to 270
electoral votes then it would be the
House of Representatives and the Senate
that would decide and that then it would
be the opportunity for the Republicans
who now realize that Trump is a disaster
to select Evan McMullen and his running
mate who's name is escaping me now I
apologize to handpick Evan McMullen to
be the next president of the United
States this is a total and utter fantasy
right it's not even likely that McMullen
is going to win Utah but I've said it
before I'll say it again the fact that
the Republican nominee does not have you
Todd guaranteed is stunning yeah that
whole scenarios kind of far-fetched I
would say of course playing spoiler I
just hope he wins cuz we haven't had a
third party when a state sent George
Wallace in 1968 yep no doubt about it
and Democrats and in red states they
smell blood in the water and they are
getting out to vote clearly it is not a
lost cause we've talked about Georgia
and Texas with the potential to be swing
states this year North Carolina looks
like it's going to be blue and if and
this is a very unlikely if if Hillary
Clinton or Evan McMullen end up taking
you to I think Trump will end up winning
but by a little bit it would be a just
slap in the face to Donald Trump
Republicans who thought this is our guy
he is not an insider although the
billionaire who uses money to buy
politicians in Washington and is proud
of it not exactly an outsider to the
political system right uh this is going
to be a very very serious and of course
trumpet you know Trump believe me I've
hired the bat best investigators
tremendous investigators okay the best
they're looking into Utah they're taking
a look at utah's papers i'm not sure
what they'll find but people are saying
utah is not a state Pat and Trump has
the best people looking into that right
now what's funny to is
he's actually sending his running mate
mike pence the campaign in Utah yeah who
would think that in the last few weeks
in the election cycle you need to send
one of your big operatives to you Tommy
John saying it's it's unheard of Romney
I think and I mean rami a Mormon
understandably hi Mormon population
there I think Romney ended up with like
73 or so 68 or seventy-three percent of
the vote in Utah just overwhelmingly red
and Trump may pull it all out to uh all
to the vote rigging thing and he might
as well come out and say Massachusetts
in Virginia those aren't even states
those are Commonwealth's this is America
we're going to have a country here we're
going to have States no Commonwealth's
voting i'm suing crooked Hillary getting
these votes in Commonwealth it's all
rigged Pat well it's funny cuz even back
in the primaries Trump was talking about
how he would have a chance in New York
in California now he can't even hold his
own ground yet ninety-nine point nine
percent chance of Hillary Clinton
winning Massachusetts in New York and
California all these states according to
nate silver's 538 forecast Trump just
doesn't know what he's talking about
that's really not a surprise to anybody
today's program is made possible in part
by custom menswear line indochino i
recently got my new custom measured suit
from indochino and the experience was
awesome I went into the Boston showroom
and worked with Chris it's one of nine
showrooms around the country measured me
for my suit gave me suggestions and
ideas because I have no clue whatsoever
what a suit should actually look like I
was able to make selections with Chris's
advice in terms of the suit pattern the
fabric the buttons the pocket style even
the lining I went in this week to try it
on some small tailoring adjustments are
being made and I'm picking up my new
suit next week you can do this by
dropping by one of the nine north
american showrooms but if you don't live
near an indochino location you can go to
indochino dot-com submit your
measurements they'll explain to you how
to take all of the necessary
measurements and you can customize your
suit in the exact same way that I did in
the showroom this week my listeners can
get any premium indochino suit for 389 @
indochino com if
you must enter the promo code Pakman at
checkout that is fifty percent off the
regular price for a made-to-measure
premium suit plus shipping is of course
free satisfaction guaranteed or your
money back so again that's indochino
dot-com promo code Pakman PA que ma and
for any premium suit just 389 and free
shipping very good experience that I had
and I encourage you to check it out